aux quinze jours nouveau genre pour
initier des jeunes de 5 à 12 ans à 18
cependant différent peut-être premier
élan vers une potentielle participation
aux jeux du québec
est-ce que vous avez découvert ces neuf
semaines sous 15 jours
les premiers jeux sont organisés en
collaboration avec les fédérations
sportives québécoises qui misent sur
leurs experts pour attirer de nouveaux
joueurs dans leur cours comme à ben
jawad
non c'est là le frisbee si ça que je
faisais et l'or puisque je sais qu'il ya
un sport high des poids est tous là
j'aimerais mieux et essayer d'en faire
et en super de faire découvrir ce sport
qui est pour moi une véritable passion à
des jeunes comme ça moi j'ai découvert
le sport assez tard et c'est vrai que je
me dis que j'aurais bien aimé pourra
participer à des camps de jour comme ça
pour découvrir plus tôt ce sport on
prend le fleuret on essaie de ne pas se
promener comme ça plusieurs activités
ont lieu sur les plateaux de l'institut
national du sport au stade olympique
l'escrimeuse escrimeurs avoue fleuret
j'attaque pas elle a bloqué ce que le
faire points
non les jeunes ne décide pas le sport
qu'il fait mais il est vraiment en
contact avec l'ensemble des sports à la
programme donc dont je un jour dans une
journée on touche environ quatre sports
différents
[Musique]
enlève ton masque et devient et ce
climat maintenant je fais les screen
déjà essayé d ce qui est ce que tu sais
que ton entraîneur est déjà allée aux
jeux olympiques aux jeux olympiques lors
des deux oui mon but c'est vraiment de
cerner qu'il pleuve peut-être un
intellectuel qui est plus un sportif
dans l'âme qui tout cela est en fait
juste leur donner une petite piqûre
comme ça et ensuite ce très bon hockey
et amjad l'apprenti escrime à a fait ses
devoirs
aujourd'hui j'ai comme découvert un
genre de technique dans les scream pour
la défense c'est que quand ils attaquent
faucheux faut que tu prennes ton épée de
tutoriaux c'est que tu pousses pour le
touché
jean françois poirier et du canada
montréal
[Musique]